Okay.
Well today we return to the main political and Louisiana astrical narrative
leading up to the hour.
Do you mind leading up to the outbreak of the civil wars in the mid 17th
century?
Um,
we left our discussion of the Elizabethan Church,
uh,
two weeks ago with the situation of relative calm at the end of Elizabeth's
reign.
If you remember,
the domestic threat posed by the Catholic minority was diminishing.
Puritan attempts to change the structure of the church through action in
parliament had been defeated.
And to large extent that relative stability can be said to have persisted into
the first two decades of the 17th century.
That is into the reign of James the first who came to the throne in 1,603 and
died in 1625.
And indeed,
the continuity's between the end of Elizabeth's reign and the reign of James
have led some historians to speak of what they call it,
Jack Up,
Ethan consensus in the church during this generation Jacobean plus Elizabethan,
Jakob,
Ethan.
The characteristics of that consensus can be perhaps illustrated with reference
to an event at the very start of James's rain in 1,603 as he made his way south
from Edinburgh to be crowned in London,
he was presented with what's become known as the millennium military petition,
getting that name from the fact that it was allegedly subscribed by a thousand
ministers of the Church of England and it revealed a body of opinion within the
church petitioning James in the hope that he would countenance further reform,
further reform in doctrine in the ceremonies of the church and in the quality of
the clergy
that led James to call the Hampton Court conference in 1,604 which was a
conference of leading churchman in which all strands of opinion we're
represented in the course of the conference.
James was very forthright in insisting that he would not countenance any change
in the episcopal government of the Church of England.
Twice in the course of the debates,
he intervene famously with the phrase no bishop,
no king.
He'd had quite enough of the semi independent Presbyterian Church of Scotland.
So discussion of church government in that sense was not on the agenda.
Still.
It wasn't a confrontation between James and the puritan wing of the Church of
England.
He was very comfortable with the godly issues that were raised.
He was very keen on steps to improve the learning and quality of the clergy.
He agreed that there should be a new English translation of the Bible.
The one eventually published in 1611 known in Britain as the authorized version,
or here is the King James Bible.
And everyone was very impressed with the kings doctrinal knowledge.
He'd had a very thorough theological education in Scotland.
There was no question,
in other words,
that James was a godly prince.
He was England Solomon as they flatteringly termed him.
So the Hampton Court conference revealed the existence of continuing
differences,
differences of opinion about aspects of the Church of England structure.
But there was a great deal of common ground and the conference broke up pretty
amicably.
Let's look at that common ground a little closely,
a little more closely.
Um,
first of all,
there was by the early 17th century and essential consensus over doctrine since
the late 50 [inaudible] he's most theologically theologians in the universities
had been interpreting the ambiguities of the Elizabethan settlement in an
essentially Calvinist way.
They tended to accept the doctrine of predestination,
the view that God had predestined those who would be amongst the elect and those
who would be reprobate or damned at the last judgment.
They also had a widely shared model of the ideal godly Protestant devotional
life based on biblicism attendance at sermons,
uh,
the practice of household devotions and a strict godly conversation as they
called it.
That is strict personal behavior,
strict moral behavior in daily life.
All of this was supported by a growing vernacular religious literature,
which tended to support this approach to religious life.
They also shared a common view of the need to entrench Protestant doctrine and
reformed behavior in the population at large.
Only a minority might be saved according to Calvinist doctrine,
but no one knew for sure who they were.
Therefore,
the church must address the whole population.
It must serve the whole population and it should minister to them.
That's interesting.
For example,
that when the 1611 translation was being prepared by a committee of divine's,
when they'd settled on a translation of a passage,
they used to read it aloud to see if it would be effective when read aloud to
illiterate congregations.
It we're very conscious of the need to be able to communicate in that kind of
way.
Well,
to that end,
a great deal of stress was placed on the provision of a godly pastorate of
teaching,
preaching ministers,
and as we saw when looking at education,
a great deal was in fact achieved in that respect.
By the early 16 hundreds there was also an unmistakable Protestant identity
despite internal differences of opinion.
Most people were conscious of their common membership of a Protestant
confessional family.
Within Europe.
There are feelings of religious hostility were directed outwards towards the
threat of what they usually described,
not as Catholicism,
but as Potpourri.
Potpourri was the supposed antithesis of reformed religion characterized as a
church which was based not on the pure unvarnished word of scripture,
but on human errors,
corrupted by false doctrine and superstitious practices and increasingly seen as
alien.
Okay,
well there's a good deal to be said for this notion of a,
a booth and consensus in the generation which span the last years of Elizabeth
and the reign of James.
But if the church was indeed at relative peace,
it was enjoying a period of stability that was in many ways fragile.
One mustn't overdo the element of consensus and by the 1620s there was
increasing evidence of that consensus being subject to destabilizing forces.
And there were two of them in particular to emphasize.
First of all,
there was the process of what one can call puritan reformation down in the
parishes.
And secondly,
there was the Armenian reaction at the center.
And I look at each of these in turn.
Well,
starting with the puritans,
the puritans,
as we've already seen where those that contemporaries thought of as in the
phrase of the time,
the hotter sot of Protestants,
those who were most committed to furthering the reformation and by furthering
the reformation,
they meant not simply conformity to a Protestant religious settlement.
They also had the ambition of galvanizing the religious life of the whole
nation.
As one of them put it,
they sought a reduction of all things disordered,
be it in religion or in social morality or reduction of it to the model of God's
requirements as revealed in scripture as they saw it.
These,
but of course people are fervent faith and a stringent personal religious life.
It's best revealed in the way they monitored their own lives in the spiritual
diaries that they often kept straining by examination of their own behavior to
achieve the sanctification of personal life,
which would give them assurance of their election assurance that they were
amongst the elect,
those who would be saved and assurance,
which often simply didn't come to many of them,
but they kept struggling and that struggle bread,
a kind of spiritual anxiety which perhaps underlay they're often vigorous
activism.
They sought reassurance often in action.
These were not just formal members of the church living their lives within a
general framework of Christian belief and practice.
They were seriously religious people and their religion shape their whole lives.
The trouble was that it not only shaped their lives,
but not infrequently impacted also on the lives of others
amongst the clergy.
Those of puritanical inclination were amongst the most conscientious and the
most active in the task of evangelizing the people,
whatever their private preferences as to forms of church government.
Most of them had long ago abandoned any serious attempt to transform the church
by political action.
They'd withdrawn from that.
After the 1580s.
Instead,
they conformed more or less to the requirements of the church for the sake of
the larger task of spreading the word evangelizing.
Protestantism seemed to them to demand popular enlightenment.
It demanded a dispelling of what they viewed as the darkness of Popek ignorance
and superstition and Godly ministers entered upon that task with very high
expectations.
When one reads their works,
they often speak initially of the mass of the population as hungry sheep unfed.
Uh,
they described them as,
as fields of corn ripe for the harvest,
or they're,
they're babes crying for the milk of good doctrine and what could stand against
the word if it was brought to them.
Unfortunately,
for that optimistic position,
they often found that their own parishioners tended to disappoint their high
hopes of evangelical success.
A parish ministry day by day,
week by week,
year by year could often be a deeply disillusioning experience.
Richard Green,
him who was one of the most famous of the early puritan preachers,
he was the minister of Dry Drayton near Cambridge,
a man much sought after for advice by other puritans.
Richard Green,
him finally resigned his living a dry Drake and after 20 years of effort effort,
which had him not only preaching on Sundays and on weekdays,
but even going out and standing by the fields as his parishioners went out to
uh,
work on their farms to talk to them about matters of religion and so forth.
After 20 years of this effort he gave up because of what he called the
untractable illness and unteachable newness of that people
and the gradually grew up in the early decades of the 17th century alongside the
literature of sermons and devotional works,
what one can perhaps describe as a literature of Godly disillusionment in which
people reflected upon their lack of success in the evangelizing movement
and such literature very often contained a very somber assessment of the state
of popular religion in England.
And I'll give you some quotations from the kind of things they tended to say.
They were deeply concerned about the fact that the people were ignorant of
doctrine on instructed in what they saw as saving doc trinal knowledge.
To give some examples from these works.
The poor people do not understand so much as the Lord's prayer if any question
be put to them as concerning religion,
they grow as mute as fish.
Men can talk understandingly about ways of the world,
but they can scarcely speak a word of sense about matters of salvation.
Our sermons are but a breath from us and a sound to them because they didn't
understand the half of it.
These are all quotations from works of this kind.
They said that the religion of the people remained one of formality and blind
devotion.
That's a common phrase.
Formality and blind devotion,
reliance upon a ritualistic repetition of one's prayers,
turning up at church services more as a gathering of neighbors.
Then as a congregation of the faithful,
more concerned with who they saw church then with what they heard and confident
that this was enough,
that this was a good life,
which in the eyes of the godly ministers,
of course it wasn't.
The people were superstitious.
They still adhere to practices which they were too ignorant to recognize as
being hangovers from the dark age of popery.
They practiced magic.
They visited cunning folk and they were profane are people who did not
appreciate the need to sanctify their lives according to the word of God and who
maintained forms of customary behavior offensive to God.
They swore they drank to excess.
They indulged in what one minister described as light viewed and lascivious
dancing.
They broke the sabbath either by working in their farms and workshops or by
their leisure activities hanging out in the Ale House as soon as they got out of
church
as one preacher put it,
every parish has a profane and ignorant multitude who are born with a pope in
their belly,
by which he meant they were directed by their fleshly appetites,
born with a popup in their belly and are not yet redeemed from that gross
supervision,
a superstition and vain conversation,
which they have received by tradition from their fathers.
In short,
they were prisoners of popular custom rather than followers of the precept of
scripture,
but there was a remedy for all of this and these condemnatory jeremiads tended
to be followed rapidly by calls for the pursuit of reformation of these
disorders by a dual policy,
a policy of word and sword ministers and secular magistrates,
whether they be parish officers or justices of the peace,
the leaders of towns or parliamentary members,
they should all act together.
The word of the minister would reform the inside of the people.
The Sword of the magistrate would conform the outside word and sword.
What's that?
Recommendations didn't fall on deaf ears and we're godly ministers and
likeminded local officers and magistrates supported one another as they
sometimes did this kind of answer to the cultural failings of the reformation.
It's failings to adequately communicate with the people down in the parishes led
to what's been characterized as widespread cultural conflict in the early 17th
century right down at the level of the locality,
many forms of customer he popular culture in the parishes were attacked.
Feasts and festivities,
Sunday dancing's and so forth.
We're often put down partly because they were held on the Sabbath Day,
partly because they tempted people to profane behavior,
notably drunkenness and the incitement of lust.
One study by Ronald Hutton in the rise and fall of merry England shows how
gradually these traditional feasts and festivals disappeared all over
southeastern England and we're gradually retreating into the north and west
where they continued to survive.
There was also widespread attack at local level upon such things as the numerous
alehouses which the people frequented,
many of them were suppressed and at such a common everyday sins as profane
swearing,
for example,
swearing by God.
In the course of conversation.
The arrest book for the town of Dorchester,
which was dominated by a puritan group from the 1610s onwards is quite
interesting.
On market days,
it reveals numerous cases of people arrested on market day for swearing in the
marketplace or for getting drunk in the taverns around the market.
That was a field day for reformation.
As a result,
some communities became well known as models of Godly discipline.
Often they were small towns,
places like Banbury in Oxfordshire,
which was known for what was described approvingly as its precise course of
government.
It's imposition locally off stricter standards of reformation or Dorchester
endorser,
which I've already mentioned under its patriarch John White or indeed Stratford
on Avon in Warrick shirt,
where the local puritan group triumphed after a sharp tussle with their
opponents.
The opponents in fact,
including a number of friends and associates of the retired playwright William
Shakespeare.
Other communities remained uneasily divided.
They were prone to occasional eruptions of conflict brought on by reforming
initiatives,
local attempts to tighten up on standards of church attendance to put down ale
houses or whatever the case.
And there might be no lasting victory just to continue in tussle between the two
sides.
Still,
others remained relatively untouched
and number of historians have looked at all of this and tried to interpret its
broader implications.
Uh,
David under,
for example,
in the study of what was going on in the west of England,
has speculated about the possible association between different local social and
economic structures and different degrees of proneness or susceptibility to the
outbreak.
Of this kind of religious conflict.
He asks why some places seem to have been able to exclude such conflict,
whereas others were deeply divided and riven by it.
Why did the puritan word take root so much better in some places and in others?
Uh,
in the east of England,
especially the counties of East Anglia where the puritans very much called the
tune by the second quarter of the 17th,
a number of scholars,
William Hunt,
myself and others have suggested that religious impulses for reformation and
greater discipline was super imposed in these areas upon other forms of social
tension that the puritan ministers tended to when they're converts principally
amongst what were known as the better sort of parishioners,
the more prosperous leaders of the parish,
the more literate people and that local struggles were aimed primarily at
disciplining the poor and the young of the communities.
In other words,
that religious anxieties and social anxieties reinforced one another,
one mutating into the other still.
Others have insisted that the whole thing was purely or a religious matter,
that if there was a corrugation or a segmenting of local populations according
to one or another religious persuasion,
it was simply a matter of the introduction of particular religious messages and
the intensity with which those beliefs were held in particular places.
So there are different takes on the unevenness of Puritan success,
but what one can say in general is that it was very uneven.
Nevertheless,
all agree that such conflict existed in many parishes and many towns and it was
all part and parcel of the local history of the reformation in its most advanced
form.
Obviously it depended first and foremost upon the communication of the demand
for a more stringent reformation into the localities.
Those places which were least troubled by all this,
with those where these demands were never heard.
There was never a minister of Puritan persuasion or a town council of Puritan
persuasion there to instigate such ref,
ref or Maitri programs for whatever reason they found no local constituency of
supporters.
But the outcome where conflict did break out tended to depend crucially on
whether the godly or those who resisted them had most control in local decision
making,
power,
town councils,
parish vestries and so forth,
and who controlled them.
We're often crucial to the success or failure of these resumes re movements.
It's all part of the way that the longterm outcome of the reformation and the
long term development of the nature of English Protestantism was being settled
and fought out in dispersed diffuse actions taking place all over the kingdom
though rather than more common in some parts of the kingdom than in others.
And gradually by the 1620s it gave rather different complexions to the church of
England in different localities.
East Anglia was predominantly puritan.
One survey of the ministers of the,
of the three counties of East Anglia for example,
reveals that by the 1632 thirds of them could be described as puritan in
inclination.
This was a great area of Puritan strength.
There were other counties also which shed that the north and the West tended to
see much less puritan activity.
Other counties were much divided.
Okay.
And in the course of it all,
the term puritan acquired a new layer of meaning
within the Jacobean church.
Puritans could not easily be distinguished by their theology.
They couldn't easily just be distinguished by their ethical teachings.
Both of them were essentially mainstream,
but what did distinguish them was their intensity and their activism.
They were defined in a sense by a godly activism,
which when it was unleashed in a particular local context tended to maximize
stress over religious issues.
That's where they got defined in such context.
No one chose to call himself a puritan.
It was a term of abuse.
They were labeled as puritans by their opponents in such conflictual contexts.
As Patrick Collinson,
one of the greatest historians of puritanism has put it.
Puritanism was not a thing definable in itself.
It was one half of a stressful relationship,
one half of a stressful relationship.
The relationship that arose in some parishes through the impact on local society
of the fervent pursuit of reformation.
Okay.
Let's turn now to the other destabilizing stabilizing group D Armenians.
And before we go any further with this,
let me stress Armenians a R,
m I n not Armenia's every year when we have the examination.
Sinister groups of Armenians turn up d stabilizing the church of England.
Uh,
there were,
there was indeed an Armenian community in Northwestern Europe at this time.
They were vitally important in the trade networks,
which linked Northwestern Europe,
uh,
to the east.
And uh,
they were there,
but they had nothing,
whatever to do with the troubles of the Church of England.
So our minions,
the Armenians were another minority who occasioned a good deal of conflict in
the early steward church.
But this time they can be defined more easily in terms of theology.
Theologically,
they comprise the minority of English churchmen who rejected Calvinism.
They rejected the Calvinist doctrine of predestination rather than believing
that only the elect were predestined to salvation.
They believed more traditionally in the universality of God's grace and in the
freewill of all mankind to choose salvation.
So the theologically distinct,
they had their antecedents in the late 16th century amongst those theologians
who did not interpret the 39 articles in a Calvinist manner,
but remained closely to ma,
closer to more traditional teaching and indeed to Lutheran teaching in their
views
in the early 17th century,
they came to be labeled Armenians after a Dutch theologian who took this
position Arminius of Laden.
His criticism of Calvin was deemed so important at the time that it was the
subject of a major conference of the reformed churches.
The synod of Dort,
which met in 1618 at which are many assists teachings were denounced,
but Arminianism also existed amongst a minority of English Churchman and it had
certain distinctive features in England.
In the Netherlands,
Arminius was operating within the context of the Dutch Reform Church with its
congregational structure.
English Armenians existed in the context of a church where the traditional
episcopal system of church government and highly traditional form of prayer book
ceremonial
the English Armenians tended to link their belief in the doctrine of free grace
to other beliefs connected to the structure of the Church of England.
They believed in episcopacy,
not simply as a form of church government amongst many others,
but as a divinely sanctioned form of church government.
They were very keen on the structure of hierarchical authority in the church.
They were also very keen on the sacraments as a means of grace as a way of
coming to God.
For example,
they restored the significance of the altar rather than of the communion table
and the significance of the communion service as something more than just a
commemoration of Christ's sacrifice,
they tended to play down preaching,
preaching,
so dear to the heart of puritans as the means of communication are many tended
to play down preaching and to place more emphasis as an element in worship.
Upon ritual,
upon the performance of the sacraments.
They spoke of the beauty of holiness.
They thought that participation,
reverend participation in services and rituals of great beauty had a spiritual
function.
They also had a very high notion of the dignity of the priesthood.
They were very clerical list in that sense and their most prominent spokesman
where leading clerics,
people like Lancelot Andrews,
the Bishop of Winchester,
Bishop Richard Neal,
the bishop of Durham and above all William Lord,
all of his names are on your handout.
William Lord,
who started as an Oxford academic was master of Saint John's College Oxford and
later moved on to be dean of Gloucester cathedral and then to other hire
officers in the church.
As our describe,
the Armenians were a minority even amongst the bishops of the Church under James
the first that became clear at the very end of James's rain in 1624 when Richard
Montague and Armenian who was the dean of St Paul's Cathedral in London,
published his non Calvinist interpretation of the Church of England's 39
articles of religion.
This publication by Montague was widely attacked.
Indeed,
he was reproved and his interpretation was rejected by the Archbishop of
Canterbury himself who was trying to Lee a Calvinist
to most members of the church at this point in time.
The beliefs and the practices of worship which were favored by the Armenians
looked very suspicious.
They look like backsliding.
They looked like backsliding towards Rome and indeed,
although the Armenians were undoubtedly Protestants,
they were very much closer to traditional Catholic teaching in many respects,
including the fact that they regarded the Catholic church itself as being a true
church or be it a corrupted one rather than seeing it as in fact the work of
antichrist,
which was the conventional extreme Protestant interpretation.
Well,
all of this might have just remained a matter for theological debate at the
academic level if it hadn't been for two facts.
First of all,
some of the Armenians were of a singularly combative and authoritarian frame of
mind.
They were equal in their determination to impose their will to any of the most
fervent puritans whom on the whole day detested.
And secondly,
in the 1620s the Armenians succeeded in winning over to their side,
the young Prince Charles the future.
Charles the first,
he was persuaded by people of Armenian convictions that their brand of religion
was more suited to a monarchy.
He liked it.
What?
In 1625 Charles came to the throne on the death of James the first and as head
of the church.
He rapidly seize the opportunity to advance Armenians in the church and to
exclude Calvinists,
and it all happened remarkably quickly.
In 1626 the Duke of Buckingham,
Charles,
his favorite and mentor was appointed Chancellor of the University of Cambridge
where he used his power as chancellor to forbid the teaching of predestination.
In 1627 William Lord and Richard Neal were appointed to the Royal Privy Council.
Very unusual move.
It had been ref for even the highest clerics to be admitted to the center of
power in that kind of way.
But Charles did it in 1628 Charles as supreme head of the church,
insisted that an Armenian interpretation of the 39 articles of religion,
the same interpretation which had been denounced when put forward only four
years earlier,
was the only valid interpretation.
In the same year,
William Lord was promoted to be Bishop of London.
That was a crucial office,
not only presiding over the metropolis of course,
but it was also an office which gave the bishop the power to control the
licensing of all books,
which were printed and published in London.
And Lord use that power of control of the press to further his own views and to
silence his critics by refusing licenses for the publication of their works.
In 1630 Lord was appointed Chancellor of the University of Oxford with
predictable results as regards to theological teaching at Oxford.
In 1632 Richard Neal was appointed archbishop of York governing the northern
province of the church.
And finally in 1633 on the death of his predecessor,
George Abbott Lord was appointed Archbishop of Canterbury.
So in only eight years,
the Armenians with Charles's help had captured the church of England.
They held all the most important positions.
If Puritan activism in the parishes had done a good deal to disturb the
localities and to create tensions over religion down in the provinces,
the Armenian victory in the church utterly shattered.
The Jakob Ethan consensus within which puritan evangelists in the localities had
been able to shelter.
William Lord simply detested puritans more than that's he detested Calvinists
and he defined all Calvinists as puritans.
He drove them together out of their shared hot hostility to what to them seem to
be innovations in the church.
Alien innovations,
which was suspiciously poppish looking a program of change in the church which
filled them with dread.
All of this served from both sides to politicize religion at the national level
in a way that really hadn't been known since the 15th Eighties
in 1626 lord had preached a sermon to parliament when it met alleging the
existence of a puritan and Presbyterian conspiracy to undermine the church of
England from within and he denounced all those who didn't share his own views as
being puritan subversives.
In 1628 many members of parliament when it met again reciprocated by condemning
Lord and the Armenian innovations which had been introduced in the meantime and
they began indulging in their own name calling one member of the House of
Commons,
Frances rouse,
declared an Armenian is bucked a spawn of a papist in the House of Lords.
The Earl of Bedford Puritan Aristocrat described Armenians as the quote him,
the little thief put in at the window of the church to unlock the door the
little thief put in at the window of the church to unlock the door to unlock the
door to whom
to popery of course,
and it's European champions who successes in the 1620s in the 30 years war,
which had been raging in Europe since 1618 just exacerbated the sense of
English,
Protestants of being embattled against powerful enemies and exposed to a
resurgent counter-reformation Catholicism.
The war was going on in Germany,
was in fact immensely complex in its origins outside observers.
It looked like an essentially religious struggle and in a 1620s the armies of
Spain fighting against the Netherlands and the armies of the Austrian emperor a
Catholic.
Of course,
we're winning and seem to be driving back Protestantism in Germany.
All this fuel,
the paranoia of those who observed at all from outside.
Well,
the rise of feeling of that kind of should have warned Charles the first.
It would almost certainly have warned his shrewd and Kenny father,
King James.
But Charles appears to have been indifferent to the polarization of opinion.
He lacked his father's political good sense and he allowed William Lord to press
ahead
between 60 and 1630 and 1632 when he was bishop of London.
Lord was extremely active in East Anglia,
part of which fell under the bishopric of London in rooting out puritans in
calling them before him to be examined on their beliefs in suspending them.
Indeed,
in ejecting them from the church,
many of them joined the migration to New England,
sometimes taking key members of their congregations with them.
The minister of tiling an Esic,
for example of parish.
Little parish down in central Essex,
left when brow beat after being browbeaten by,
by Lord and deprived of his living and talk with him.
13 members of his community,
they founded Rocksbury,
Massachusetts in 1633 once he had become Archbishop of Canterbury,
Lord ordered that communion tables should be removed from their position close
to the center of the chancellor and they should be placed at the east end of the
church like altars,
suitably dressed in a appropriate cloths and railed in to create a holy space at
the east end of the chance.
This was anathema to puritans,
but he required it and he used his metropolitan bit visitation as archbishop to
demand conformity to this new ritualism in every church.
Church wardens who refuse to obey,
we're hold before him and sometimes punished.
In 1633 he also issued what was known as the book of Sports,
a declaration in the king's name that traditional sports,
festivities and leisure activities would be permitted upon Sundays and every
minister was ordered to read it out in his church.
This again was anathema to puritan ministers.
Many refused to do it and they were punished and deprived of their livings
altogether.
Throughout the Armenian controlled church and new and stricter definition of the
nature of Anglican conformity was being rigorously enforced by Lord and he had a
very sharp way indeed of dealing with dissidents.
Three of the most famous dissidents who smuggled in Antioch Aminian books from
the Netherlands to escape.
Lord Censorship of the press were arrested in 1637 38 and severely punished by
Lord,
acting from the Court of star chamber,
of which he was a leading member.
They were pilloried.
They had their ears slit off,
for example,
and the result of all this,
well,
one result was a far more rapid growth of the puritan colonies in New England
than would otherwise have been the case.
Thousands of the most dedicated of the puritan clergy and groups of their leg
followers.
Finally despaired of England,
despaired of the hope of reformation in this context and left to create a godly
Commonwealth of their own in the new world
and within England.
Well,
it's possible that in some perhaps many parishes,
some aspects of Lords,
Armenian policies were perhaps not unwelcome.
One could say that it was a way of putting an end to the parochial controversy
and reasserting order and discipline in the church.
Some may well have welcomed that it offered a doctrine of salvation,
which was somewhat easier and more generous than Calvin is predestination,
perhaps closer to the needs and understandings of simple folk
and perhaps the brand of religious practice focused on the prayer book and the
sacraments,
which was something which might be more inclusive at the level of the parish,
less individually demanding on the population.
Perhaps all these positive features have been suggested.
It an interesting book by Judith be on attitudes towards the prayer book in this
period,
but in many parishes it was also the case that the policies of William Lord and
the Armenians themselves brought conflict.
There was widespread alarm at their ceremonial innovations.
There was widespread suspicion of their ultimate intentions.
There was widespread resentment and frustration amongst the godly folk who
remained in English parishes that the reformation had been stopped,
that perhaps it was being reversed before it had even been half one
that's in itself was a new course for discontent,
a new cause for controversy,
a new cause for what had been called street wars of religion,
a source of increased bitterness in such controversies,
a bitterness which spilled over into political life,
sharpening and intensifying other sources of conflict,
which we're coming to light between the royal government and members of the
political nation,
and it's to those other sources of conflict that I'll turn next time.